[Music]
three two one
humanitarian needs have never been so
high armed conflicts are resurging
remaining the number one driver of
humanitarian needs something the world
could witness with brutal russian
military aggression against ukraine
climate change is increasingly adding to
the plight
in fact
after decades famine is re-emerging
pushing entire populations to the very
brink of survival
the kovit-19 pandemic only exacerbated
the pre-existing fragilities but there
is more bad news
the record high humanitarian needs will
only continue to grow
the available funding already meets less
than 50 percent of the needs due to
donor economies pandemic fallout this
funding gap is likely to grow further
to make matters worse
the very delivery of humanitarian aid is
getting more dangerous
innocent civilians
mostly women and children schools
hospitals even humanitarian workers are
increasingly targeted
often in blatant violation of
international humanitarian law
this is why it is imperative that the
international community steps up
together with the member states the eu
has been the world's leading
humanitarian donor for some time
for the eu
cooperation with a diverse network of
partners working on the ground
is crucial
yet
to be able to continue to provide a
lifeline to millions in need we need to
deliver better
together
you